daniel ortega allana el camino para su
reelección el consejo supremo electoral
de nicaragua en manos del oficialismo
inhabilitó al partido derechista alianza
ciudadanos por la libertad para que
participe en las elecciones generales
del próximo 7 de noviembre que la
organización partidos políticos
ciudadanos por la libertad sé por él ha
venido teniendo comportamiento fuera de
las condiciones y regulaciones técnicas
legales para esta clase de organizar y
organizaciones políticas particularmente
ha realizado manifestaciones de manera
reiterada mediante actos verbales que
menoscaban la independencia la soberanía
y la autodeterminación lo que según su
consideración son meritorias de la
cancelación de su personalidad súbita la
agrupación denunció la acción del
consejo supremo electoral y también que
a su presidenta carmen a rogers unborn
conocida en el ámbito político como
kitty monterrey le fuera cancelada su
cédula de identidad nicaragüense lo que
la deja como ciudadana estadounidense su
otra nacionalidad y con una situación
migratoria
complicado poco después de la
inhabilitación de alianzas ciudadanos
por la libertad el candidato a la
presidencia del derechista partido
liberal constitucionalista anunció que
estudiaba renunciar a su postulación en
protestas ya que su propio partido pidió
la anulación del movimiento de monterrey
aunque nosotros reducimos como candidato
del oficial del partido pero luego
nosotras buscar a luchar adentro del
partido y ante un llamado a todo esto
del 12 por l que aquí nos juntemos todos
y hagamos la lucha con al menos 31
líderes opositores detenidos desde junio
entre ellos siete aspirantes a la
presidencia daniel ortega marca el
camino a su quinto mandato de cinco años
cuarto de forma consecutiva y segundo
junto a su esposa
la vicepresidenta rosario murillo